what do you think you're gonna do when
you retire I don't know you don't think
about it all I do think about it um the
main thing is make sure that before I'm
retired my kids are set for life with
their universities with their houses all
that stuff that's number one go then
when I retire out and I got a lot of
options I could do you know I gotta see
which one I'm gonna like the most cuz
whatever I'm gonna do obviously nothing
out love as much as fighting nothing
don't make me wake up at 6:00 in the
morning to go fucking run no nothing to
have that loving me when you asked about
that longevity is just cuz I love it so
much I don't have to work for it I just
I love it I love what I do even hitting
the bag for 35 or 40 minutes sometimes
is so fucking boring and monotonous if I
got the right music going on I mean a
little bit of water let's do it you know
am I have fun doing it you know so I
gotta just find something that my heart
is solely in and I'm having fun I still
haven't figured out what that is you
know maybe skiing you know every scheme
the skiers are trying to recruit me like
you're is this guy minutes we need this
guy over here in our team - it may be
scheming that she gets my blood pumping
you know really you like skiing I hate
it I love this I always worry about
falling - that's your problem
it's my problem looking snowman is gonna
happen yeah you can click on the head
you can now but I have their fucking ACL
torn apart I've already had two knee
reconstruction when I go down the hill
I'm like don't get hurt don't get hurt
don't get hurt that didn't hurt that's
so crazy I'm brain thinkers I'm thinking
there's no way I can get hurt those
things I'm just fucking going as fast as
I can
oh you're one of those guys yeah there's
no way I could get hurt it's fucking
snow oh you could definitely get hurt
yeah definitely fucking up while I was
standing still like that's my friend hey
guys down - say what's up and just like
some seven-year-old man didn't see that
I'm stopped not moving you and just
fucking hit me into the kneecaps good
thing there's so more flexible nothing
tore nothing it was like a good hit
though you know like a good little low
kick out of nowhere you know I worry
about that with my kids
some clodhopper if they start young
though
- forget about oh yeah they're already
doing black diamonds little fuckers yeah
yeah they're so low to the ground
they're tiny you know the the will skis
and shit they no fear 30 no fear
once they already fun alone once or
twice it yeah it's just snow I watched
some of those fucking men going down
those hills though oh shit Shh like when
they drive them off in the helical my
god oh that's ridiculous I watched a
video the other night of a guy went down
this mountain that no one's ever skied
down before they dropped him off at the
top and he had to climb the first couple
of feet down with the skis on before he
got to this open chute I was like what
and the fuck are you doing he's climbing
like you can't just ski this rocks
everywhere you shit that's great fuck
you that blows my mother better hobby
his ridiculous sliding down a mountain I
might end up in there was exactly not no
time soon cuz those guys are a lifetime
of skill but I wouldn't I wouldn't uh
take it off you know I got I'd love to
ski one of those crazy mountains that
are just fucking SuperDuper steep and
just rip it you know one thing about
skiing is you could do it when you're
old
yeah cuz this lady who was teaching my
daughter she was giving my daughter
lessons at this ski place she was like
deep in north 60s
she was skiing great well they got
technique technique yeah I grew up in
the snow I so she did I was like 30 you
know so I got a lot of catching up to do
yeah yeah it's uh
I just know two video I'm like re my
friend are he broke his wrist last year
and he broke his ankle two years ago
he's always fucking himself up is that
guy balls to the wall I don't know he
probably is on mushrooms well that's a
good time to ski that's right that's the
best time I know a couple people that
have done on mushrooms
they say you ski really yeah you like it
what's the best thing about skiing on
mushrooms well it could go both ways
because it fuck's up your depth
perception you know I don't know where
the trees are so though the first time I
did it I was like super grandma you know
like everybody's like what's wrong with
him like no no just because the snow is
all the same - right so now it just fox
fur you depth perception so bad you know
you don't see whether divots in the snow
yeah everything gets pixelated yeah oh
you're a really trippin hard then oh man
everything is like the same and I can't
really see the bumps and then I I don't
see the bumps I just feel him in all
right I'm gonna need the toughness one
now in the story you know and then the
next time I did it it allowed a little
less of a dosage had a blast you know
yeah they say it's a it's a micro dose
thing yes just like don't take like
three grams take like a half a gram yeah
something like that well the first time
I was doing the bro science it was like
yeah I think it's like four grams is
cool man let's go like on a fat I'm done
like a slight fast you know you're the
problem with it that division thing when
things when you do the mushrooms and
things get pixelated well you see like
almost like a matrix around you that
yeah I would imagine that that would
fuck you up skiing you wouldn't be able
to see all the creases in the snow and
shit and you just feel it all of a
sudden you have a snowboard I did it for
like half a day I was pretty cool but I
I used to ski like inline like you know
parks you know like on ramps on half
pipes probably yeah so I could like jump
on rails and half pipes and I could even
do like a front flip on on my skate but
this is not the season yeah yeah
so skiing came very easy to meet and
snowboarding not so much because I
didn't skateboard when I was a kid mmm i
skateboard as a kid but i've never
snowboarded but the people that do it
they say it's easier to get better at
snowboarding there's to get better at
skiing they say it's like it's hard in
the beginning but once you get it it's
easier to get better it okay but when
you fall a lot of latitudes fall this
the snowboard goes up in the air your
feet are stuck on it you land right on
your fucking head a lot of people get
knocked the fuck out cuz you can't move
your legs individually like you can if
you're skiing and you then on the
tailbone a lot - a lot of people tell me
yeah and if you're skiing and you land
funky to ski snap loose and you move
your legs on board is shaft and yeah you
strapped in the snowboard is this shit
so there people vote through the trees
like fucking Silver Surfer ah that's fun
man yeah but that's an rush this blowin
down part with those seems different
like less options to slow down I love
all that anything he gets my heart
pumping they do skydive or anything
crazy like that I have
the skydiving cuz I'm afraid of the nerd
bad stories about the landing how you
are with the skiing you got a couple
buddies he got in her I got a couple
buddies they got in her on the landing
of skydiving alright I can't do that I'm
fighting so I'm fighting whoo yeah